ça vous dit d'aller voir les moteurs un
peu derrière certains n'ont même pas 10
ans et déjà on les invite à s'aventurer
dans les entrailles d'un hélicoptère un
hélicoptère mais pas n'importe lequel
ceux qui montent à son bord sont
uniquement des gendarmes bah ça leur
permet de découvrir la gendarmerie sous
une haute figure que que l'on a
habituellement de découvrir les métiers
de la gendarmerie
déjà que le gendarme n'est pas seulement
au bord de la route en train de faire la
répression leur montrer toutes les
facettes des métiers que l'on peut avoir
prochainement
ça te fait rêver ça bah oui quand même
enfin pourrait piloter un hélicoptère ça
serait bien si les enfants ont des
étoiles plein les yeux aujourd'hui il
s'agit aussi là pour les gendarmes de
mettre des visages sur un métier on fait
un principalement des enquêtes et du
secours à personnes
et si on par exemple on récupère un
blessé est qu on a tout démonté derrière
et bien on peut le mettre sur une
civière
et puis leur monter à bord et l'emmener
par exemple directement l'hôpital bocage
s'il ya besoin
je leur en ai parlé il y en a ils se
sont inscrits et exprès pour venir tenir
aujourd'hui oui c'est pas tous les jours
qu'on a l'occasion de venir visiter la
base est la base aérienne la découverte
continue les élèves officiers ont
préparé une petite surprise à leurs
gendarmes en dire c'est parti pour un
parcours du combattant en duo 17 ans et
par l'adulte de l'enfant le temps de
cette course
ils doivent apprendre à se faire
confiance sur le terrain ça peut ça
faisait écouter l'un l'autre
donc là c'est surtout de communiquer
d'échanger et puis et puis voilà qui
prennent un peu de plaisir aussi à faire
ça se faire plaisir et peut être un jour
enfilé l'uniforme de gendarmes pour de
vrai cette fois ci
[Musique]